first thing that struck me the most when
i first came was the speed in which
things get done here was like things
that in brazil so i mean biomedical
research so we do experiments most of
the time so in brazil experiments that
would take me maybe a few months to do
here that were getting done in a couple
weeks and i was like shocked at the
beginning
but then of course i understood that
this is a big advantage of being here
this is a mind broadening experience and
has given me a new perspective to life
and of course you can improve your
english
so all together
it has been a great opportunity to me
and
it has
helped me to grow personally and
professionally
after i moved here i was really
surprised in a good way how much social
and cultural life
i can experience in in new haven not
only provided by the university that is
always
with all the museums and school of art
and music they are they always have
sparkles but also the city is providing
festivals during the the spring and
during the summer so leaving all that
experience it was i think it was a
really good surprise it always amazes me
how people come here not just from
brazil but from all over the world from
germany japan italy france been to my
lab and
at the end of the time they go back to
wherever they came from um sao paulo
bella horizonte paris wherever and then
years later they tell me you know
those were the best years of my life
when i lived in new haven